[Musique]
la musique
hier est gay
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui ont fait tour à tour free farid
houas a toujours dit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les
moi
les sessions
[Musique]
moi
oui
[Musique]
les
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
séduits
[Musique]
comment vas tu
j'adore la fourmi je parie mixer ou à la
peine tout l'offre
ça va
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai
mais
m
jeudi soir
voilà
[Musique]
moi
ouais mais là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
que
[Musique]
c'est balance et nous avons balancé
l'événement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cette fois
[Applaudissements]
c'est une légende ce monsieur ouiklef
c'est juste une légende je vais traduire
et world gêne il a produit destiné plus
douce des styles et le titre the title
in exceptionnel l'album méfie vraiment
et est ce que est ce que tu peux pas
nous faire un bien des petits trucs pour
nous genre tu peux pas nous faire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'émirat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
thibault ils vont introduire connu
franchement le titre est exceptionnel on
était très très très heureux temps avec
nous c'est disponible depuis le 15
septembre
carnival fruits vraiment ce sur chez
vous vous avez qui fait votre tête j'en
ai vu des live un mail à ses voix la
revoici le patron le boss loire de boeuf
est ce qui fait aussi avec natura oui
[Applaudissements]
nous nous
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le caillou ce matin
le coup
le bouchon est coquette sa cinquante
deux frérots tulle en 48 je cite un
tweet
tu peux me l'avoir su lin cet accord
[Applaudissements]